ja also ich bin hier um erst mal zu
sagen dass ich sehr froh bin dass herr
scholz jetzt offensichtlich mit tempo
immer wieder telefoniert hatte also dass
wir jetzt eine situation haben wo jetzt
noch auf verhandlungen hoffentlich
hingearbeitet wird weil wir stehen jetzt
vor einem heißen herbst wurde eben
angesprochen die ganze mit dem liegen
auf dem tisch soziale hilfen
unterstützung panik energie industrie
bricht ein und ich glaube wir haben
jetzt eigentlich folgende situation
entweder wir sagen dieses ganze
kriegsgeschehen muss so weitergehen aber
wir federn dann die konsequenzen ab oder
wir sagen wir müssen mal ganz
grundsätzlich darüber nachdenken was
hier auf diesem kontinent passiert und
vor allen dingen was ist die europäische
rolle darin und dafür sitze ich hier
weil ich denke wir müssen aufhören auch
diesen krieg isoliert zu betrachten
es geht jetzt um eine europäische große
strategie olaf scholz war am 29
august in prag hat dort eine große rede
gemacht hat gesagt wir haben jetzt die
aufgabe dass wir die eu-erweiterung neu
denken müssen es geht oben das
beitrittsgesuch der ukraine aber auch in
vielen anderen staaten das heißt wir
haben eigentlich die aufgabe vor uns
eine große friedensordnung zu schaffen
und dazu höre ich zu wenig in der
politik sondern sehr viel kleinteiliges
ja immer nur diese kleinteiligen lösung
hier und da und das macht mir deswegen
sorgen weil ich komme aus der europa
forschung es geht ja nicht nur und bei
uns so auch in frankreich auch in
italien auch in prag auch in wien sind
riesengroße zehntausende protest am
start und die größte sorge die ich habe
ist dass wir uns über diese
protestbewegungen auch noch als europäer
auseinander dividieren und das keiner
mehr einen plan hat was wollen wir
zusammen auf diesem kontinent welches
verhandlungsangebote unterbreiten wir
und was ist die eigentlich die
europäische idee für eine
friedensordnung ich sage dass deswegen
letzter satz aber 1989 hatten wir
eigentlich zwei ziele wenn wir uns kurz
daran erinnern 30 jahre maastrichter
vertrag erwerbsloser juni davon ist
nichts mehr übrig geblieben eigentlich
heute und wir wollten noch eine
konföderation zuordnung eigentlich mit
russland auch die ist gerade sozusagen
verscherbelt das heißt wir haben uns als
europäer meilenweit von den zielen
entfernt einen friedlichen
prosperierenden kontinent zu haben und
machen jetzt eigentlich so abwicklung
szenarien die wir dann sozusagen in
kleinteiliger form irgendwie diskutieren
und da würde ich eigentlich ein großes
plädoyer machen wollen für das große
denken und eine große europäische
strategie die wir jetzt damit umgehen
würde er direkt polemisch herr sarrazin
fragen schafft sich europa ab hör seh
ich sage mit schiller es kann der
frömmste nicht in frieden leben wenn es
dem bösen nachbarn nicht gefällt damit
hat er das gesagt was was in der
gegenwärtigen lage angesagt ist alles
ist klar mit europa erst dann wenn das
thema der russland wo kleine da erledigt
dies zunächst muss völlig klar sein dass
russland niemals mal in der lage sein
wird uns uns in den nächsten jahren und
jahrzehnten zu bedrohen oder anzugreifen
und dazu bedarf es eines sieges der
ukraine und dann werden alle übrigen
europäischen fragen automatisch wieder
auf die tagesordnung kommen und davor
ist es einfach aus meiner sicht der
zeitverschwendung sich mit ihnen zu
befassen das heißt zusammengefasst ein
vereintes europa gibt es nur wenn die
ukraine gewinnt ja also ich würde noch
mal gerne zumindest ich glaube erst mal
dass wenn ich das sagen darf dass das
nun ziemlich männliches argument ist ja
diese männer verbinden lassen eine frau
ja aber diese männerfantasie mein krieg
und frieden des militärischen sieges ja
also wir haben jetzt wir haben jetzt wir
haben jetzt versuchen sie wecken gerade
die man haben muss verschiedene wochen
diskutiert mit dem großen
militärexperten ja ganz egal ob erich
vater johannes warth wie auch immer alle
leute herr kujat die wir in diesem land
haben die militärexperten sagen der
militärische sieg ist praktisch nichts
verziehen das heißt meine frage ist was
wollen wir eigentlich an strategischen
zielen passiert wie ralph lauren ja oder
ja zeigt ja keine hd abo labbadia wurde
ein
sie las was das für mich ganz wichtig
ist dass wir hier in diesem land und
nicht nur in diesem land 70 jahre lang
erzählt haben europa heißt nie wieder
krieg ja und jetzt haben wir die
fantasie dass wir europa überall den
krieg ein und ich würde das gerne
einfach mal so als these dastehen lassen
dass ich glaube als europäer verrennen
wir uns wenn wir sagen in einem krieg
einen wir europa ich glaube europa steht
für frieden das haben wir 70 jahre lang
erzählt es steht für verhandlungen und
steht für eine lösung die auf jeden fall
da können wir uns glaube ich im umdrehen
wie wir wollen wir werden eine
kooperation mit russland nach diesem
krieg irgendwie haben es ist nicht
darstellbar dass europa abgetrennt ist
von russland abgesehen davon dass die
sanktion nicht wirken das heißt wir
müssen uns hinein denken in den
kontinent danach und ich stelle nochmal
die frage was ist das europa bild das
wir haben aktionen gar nicht wirken das
kann man so hatten aber erst 21 die
ukraine und dann kommen wird zu ihrem
bomben das ist meine rein das sei gerade
wenn sie an die zu wenn sie sagen wir
müssen ja tatsächlich eben über die zeit
nach der herren was ist nach dem krieg
oder war nicht genau zu sagen was kommt
was irgendwie was genau mein problem
auch in der frage irgendwie inwiefern
können wir überhaupt russland entgegen
kommen und wie wird das verstanden in
russland sie sagen selber 89 war das
ziel einige konnte er alle
friedensordnung auch mit russland diese
friedensordnung hat ja russland
gebrochen und nicht wir also der einzige
grund warum europa gerade neu über
frieden nachdenken muss und über die
frage wie er zusammen gehalten wird ist
ja weil wir einen nachbarn haben der es
eben nicht mit frieden hält das heißt
wir haben ein aggressor im raum wenn
russland den kriegst stand zu stand
einstellt haben wir morgen wie sagen
brauchen wir gar nicht darüber sprechen
wir sagen europa wird ja in dem sinne
nur es gibt in europa nur ein aggressor
gerade so wenn wir darüber nachdenken
was kommt danach stelle ich mir eben die
frage und die stelle ich mir durchaus
auch unter dem aspekt dass ich auch
hinter dem eisernen vorhang geboren bin
und schon nimmt sozusagen erst seit 84
in deutschland bin und das heißt gerade
diese grenzländer zu russland stellen
sich alle die frage was kommt danach
wenn man wenn wir jetzt aufgeben wenn
wir die ruß wenn wir die ukraine
preisgeben ist das nicht eine ermutigung
quasi für die zeit danach jedes andere
grenzland auch gerade die kleineren
grenzländer wie sagen die die wissen was
es heißt neben russland zu leben und
lieben den frieden wer gefährt in meinen
augen gefährden wird den frieden wenn
wir jetzt die ukraine preisgeben ihre
läger überhaupt nicht vom preis gegen
mehrpreis games yog nicht mein vokabular
ich rede von einer friedensordnung auf
diesem kontinent die europa einen soll
und die perspektive in irgendeiner form
mit russland zusammen wird funktionieren
haben naja das war sehen und da muss man
glaube ich sehen und dass er das was sie
eigentlich auch ansprechen dass wir es
mit
beispielsweise einer macht wie russland
zu tun haben die sich gewissen
grundsätzen demokratischen grundsätzen
einfach entzieht und ich glaube dann ist
es gut wenn der friedliche demokratische
teil europas
für sich entscheidet wir machen eine
friedensordnung beispielsweise und ich
finde es auch wirklich schlimm dass
europa jetzt länger wieder zusammen
rückt weil es einen äußeren feind gibt
eine äußere bedrohung und man feststellt
dass es doch in der tat
gemeinsame werte gibt die es gut ist
dass man sie gemeinsam lebt dann ist es
immer wieder zwang von außen gewesen
auch wenn man an die gründung des
deutschen reiches denkt was immer zwang
von außen der dazu geführt hat dass man
sich seiner stärken nichts habe ich
möchte da noch mal reingehen also dass
das so zu sagen was sie sagen lasse ich
mal so stehen das könnte man sehr
strittig stellen aber das wollte ich
eigentlich gar nicht diskutieren ja also
es geht hat eine vorgeschichte bei
diesem krieg ja wege der aggressor ist
wer angefangen hat und beweisen dass man
das also dass man wirklich in dem
natürlich eine andere ist unstrittig den
anlagen klagen sie erwarten wir auch
nicht nach moskau hören genau ist das
ist so was von uns stehen das ist
unstrittig sagt auch mal es ist völlig
unstrittig und trotzdem kann auch
niemand negieren dass dieser krieg eine
vorgeschichte hat ja aber da ich will da
gar nicht
wohin ich möchte erst im schreibt man
immer zwei wie vor wohin ich möchte ist
dass wir eine selbst schädigende politik
in europa machen die dazu führt dass wir
vor einem heißen herbst stehen und zwar
mit blick auf niederlande frankreich
italien usw wir haben protest in allen
ländern wir haben den protest in
deutschland wir haben unternehmer die
ihr abwandern wir haben inflation heute
demonstriert
klar ihr bäcker dihk ihn deshalb und so
weiter das heißt wir machen eine selbst
schädigende politik für dieses land und
für europa das noch mein gedanke nicht
nur für uns sondern auch für die
italiener franzosen und so weiter und
die gefahr damit jetzt wieder überall
windräder darstellung gefahr die ich
sehe ist dass wir im soziale zustände
kommen die wir vielleicht auch nicht
mehr beherrschen ja und dass wir die
dann gegeneinander auflösen und dass das
was wir eigentlich wollten nämlich die
einigkeit über einen krieg dass das eine
illusion ist das ist meine these hier
das heißt ich glaube das wird so erzählt
so wie sie das aufnehmen wird das so
erzählt ja wir haben jetzt die werte in
der ukraine das verteidigen wir aber was
doch real hier am start ist ist dass wir
auflösende sich auflösende
gesellschaften haben wo die industrie
schon in panik ist wo wir eine bewegung
da müssen sie die themen trennen ich
finde ehrlich gesagt das ist das sind
für mich zwei themen die frage welche
politik sie unser land und die frage des
ukraine krieges sind eigentlich
getrennte themen die energie die
verfälscht die falsche energiepolitik
von deutschland die sich über jan einem
jahrzehnt schon an wand oder schon
länger wird gerade katalysiert durch die
sich dabei nicht aber diese situation
also dass unser dass unser
wirtschaftsminister die letzten
atomkraftwerke abschalten wenn mitten in
der großen nachher
das ist wie soll ich sagen das ist nicht
die schuld der ukraine und auch nicht
der heimat von putin sondern das ist ein
selbst gemachtes problem und ein teil
dieser probleme müssen wir sowieso
völlig abgesondert von kriegen der krieg
über handeln wenn dabei auch nicht die
hängen nicht unmittelbar mit einer
möglichen nur darauf hinweisen dass wir
eine politik machen die für europa und
diesen kontinent kolossal selbst
schädigend ist und zwar für alle
gesellschaften europas sozial
energiepolitisch aber sein oder in
manhattan gelöst wie man habe ist dass
europa das 70 jahre lang erzählt hat es
ist für frieden das wie ein
friedensangebot machen und klartext so
sagen ich glaube dass die amerikanischen
und die europäischen interessen in
diesem konflikt nicht kongruent sind und
dass wir ein größeres interesse an den
friedensverhandlungen haben wir sollten
als eu frau von der leyen macht ja
morgen eine große grundsatzrede ich
hoffe dass frau von der leyen morgen mit
welchen teil der ukraine wollen wir denn
abgehalten gibt auch keinen frieden sind
die fragen was sind denn unsere ziele in
der ukraine frage ich sie mal klar die
frage ist ja zum beispiel ist jetzt ist
jetzt ein militärisches ziel dass wir
die krippe zurückerobern das ist ja ein
richtiges
andrist bringt jemand in ihr haus ein
besetzt das erdgeschoss in den ersten
stock zurück wir sind keine klischees
wie schnell
ich bin das einfach mal durch und sie
hat in berlin verstärkt ich freu mich
genau so ist es wir spielen dass man
durch sie ziehen sich den ersten stock
ihres hauses in gemacht wenn das einmal
sagt aber doch mal ganz konkret bleibt
aber konkret wie sie ziehen sich in den
ersten stock zurück und jetzt sagen
jetzt spiele ich möchte einen ist
interessant dass sie aber immer wieder
die gleiche unter gleichen
schlussfolgerungen daraus schließt
frieden für die ukraine was ich möchte
ist eine google eine europäische ukraine
was ich möchte ist ein beitrittsgesuch
für die ukraine was ich möchte ist dass
wir die ukraine in einer gesamtschau
sehen mit den gesamten gebieten die
zwischen russland und europa legen es
geht nicht nur um die ukraine moldawien
es geht um york gibt
wir brauchen eine wirklich interessieren
was glauben sie müssten allein
das würde ich sie gerne diskussion da wo
sie steht das geht gar nicht um mich
aber gucken sie mal gucken sie in der
amerikanische diskussion ist die frage
neutralität für die ukraine und die
frage ist tatsächlich warum ist das
eigentlich nicht bartholdy und kann es
nicht bestimmen kann er weiß land kann
selbst bestimmen dass das tolle helfen
wenn man ein freies land sich an
demokratische grundsätze hält selbst zu
sagen ich möchte zu dem bündnis gehören
beispielsweise zur nato vielleicht
wollen die auch zu russland gehören dann
ist das eine freie entscheidung oder
sahne sind aber zu 90
aber ja aber es ist damit unter das
vortagestief referendums
sammlung creme eingespielt ist und
wieder bei fälschung betriebe das ist
wirklich unter ihrem niveau als das ziel
kann nur sein souveränität für die
ukraine weil wir denn eigentlich dass
wir jetzt über die ukraine verhandeln
und was die ukraine haben ich will gar
nicht so lang als einzig legitime ziel
in einem freien europa das ernst nimmt
freiheit souveränität die mutti ist doch
dass die ukraine tatsächlich frei
entscheiden kann welche zukunft sie
haben möchte auch die bevölkerung sind
die alle abstimmen in einer in einer
anständigen abstimmung und sagen sie
wollen zu russland gehören von mir aus
geht ja aber wir müssen doch wir können
doch nicht über über über ein
friedensprojekt europa reden und
gleichzeitig die ukraine auf teile hier
ist aber eine ganz spannende frage die
ich gerne stellen würde wenn sie jetzt
sagen deutschland auch so haben da
nichts mitzureden dann müsste man ja die
frage zurück stellen wie viel soll
deutschland denn dann riskieren für die
ukraine also man muss ja schon sagen
genau diese so entlarvend schicken wir
machen wirtschaftssanktionen das heißt
deutschland hat ja dann schon sich
eingemischt und dabei dann ja auch doch
auch einen anteil vielleicht dann auch
mit zu bestimmen in verhandlungen oder
nicht nur peanuts gewesen weil da kann
man ja nirgendwo sich einmischen und
kann niemand kann das moniert der nato
richtig mitgliedern hat
jeder das bündnis jedes haus und jede
ewig lang jedes gerede ich meine da
können wir auch irgendwie jede
aussenpolitik einstellen aber der konnte
er viele anmerken dass die ukraine nicht
mitglied ist das ist
und bittet um hilfe und hilfe das ist ja
kein einmischen aber dann wir helfen der
ukraine weil die ukraine uns geholt und
zinsen dagegen der schweiz heute mit
putin
für mehr ist die frage wie wir diesen
kriegen so schnell wie möglich beenden
der kolossale selbst schädiger ist für
europa energiepolitisch politisch
sozialen ist unstrittig und die türkei
hat eine ganz klare meinung nein mutter
und tanklager unter militärexperten wenn
sie auf ihren vater
dass die ukraine hält keine vier wochen
durch oder kia wird fallen
ich bin kein militär nicht mit aussagen
der experten jetzt im letzten halben
jahr eine ganze menge gehört und vieles
davon widerspricht sich das heißt ja
auch gesehen dass auch militärexperten
nicht die nicht nicht sozusagen
hundertprozentig mit dem millionär gar
nicht argumentiert sondern ich habe
argumentiert europa ist ein
friedensprojekt und ich möchte das ist
das bleibt unser angebot kommt ja und es
und ich sage es nochmal sie können
militärisch nichts gewinnen wir brauchen
eine föderale lösung auch für die
ukraine weil auch ganz europa föderal
organisiert ist und wir werden das nicht
ohne russland hinbekommen das heißt ich
gab ihm immer noch
hatten wir die hatten wir hatten am 23
februar abends hatten wir eine
europäische union die war die war
unvollkommenen darüber haben sich ja oft
geäußert und von dem man sagt einstimmig
zu die wahlen verkommen mit einer
offenen zukunft und wir hatten und wir
hatten ein der russland welches mit
krieg drohte mit einem überfall auf die
ukraine drohte und diesen überfall auf
die hilfe und zog und die ukraine ist
seit ende mai seit ende 91 ein
souveräner selbstständiger staat wo in
einer volksabstimmung 91 in einer in
einer also nicht getürkt die
vorverschiebung 91 prozent der erreichen
der bürger gesagt haben sie sind für die
unabhängigkeit davon auch 58 kinder oder
meine nein nein er ist einer in einer
völlig freien ukraine einer
international probierten abstimmung wo
alle sagen darauf war nichts gefälscht
und an diesem der völkerrechtlich
eindeutigen stand der auch von der auch
von russland mit unterschrieben wurde im
unionsstaat an diesen völkerrechtlich
eindeutigen zustand bescheinigt das
weiterziehen russland flagge helfen
feier einseitige aggression vor der
ukraine